Sagen wir, ihr schmeißt
eine Grillparty.
Doch 10 Minuten bevor
die Gäste kommen, fällt euch ein,
ihr habt vergessen,
die Getränke kalt zu stellen.
Wer hilft euch jetzt?
Richtig. Die Physik.
Heute geht es um Express-Kühlen.
Ich habe hier vier Flaschen Sprudel
und 10 Minuten Zeit.
Wie stark bekomme ich den Sprudel
in 10 Minuten abgekühlt?
So lange Flasche Nummer 1
im Gefrierfach ist,
haben wir Zeit, um zu klären, was
Wärme und Kälte eigentlich genau ist.
Alles hier in dieser Küche,
hat dieselbe Temperatur.
Nämlich Raumtemperatur.
Warum fühlt sich aber der Holztisch
wärmer an, als z.B. der Metalllöffel?
Was ich hier fühle,
ist meine eigene Körperwärme.
Dass sich der Tisch wärmer anfühlt,
heißt nichts anderes,
als das Holz ein schlechterer
Wärmeleiter ist als Metall.
Meine Körperwärme wird hier schneller
von mir weg geleitet, als bei Holz.
Wie wird Wärme weitergeleitet
und was ist Wärme genau?
Temperatur ist eigentlich nichts
anderes als die Geschwindigkeit
der Bewegung von Molekülen.
Je langsamer und weniger
sich Moleküle bewegen,
desto kälter ist es.
Und je mehr und schneller
sich Moleküle bewegen,
desto wärmer ist es.
Z.B. Wasser: Wasser ist
bei Raumtemperatur flüssig,
die Wassermoleküle sind beweglich,
Halten aber noch zusammen.
Wenn ich es erhitzte, verdampft es,
d.h., die Wassermoleküle
fliegen durch den Raum,
sie bewegen sich mehr.
Und wenn ich Wasser abkühle,
erstarrt es irgendwann zu Eis, d.h.,
die Wassermoleküle bewegen
sich nur noch sehr wenig.
Wärme wird weitergeleitet,
wenn Moleküle ihre Bewegungsenergie
aufeinander übertragen.
Sagen wir, wir haben ein schnelles
Molekül und ein langsames Molekül.
Das langsame Molekül chillt hier rum,
das schnelle kommt an
und dotzt an das andere an.
Indem wir also Moleküle abbremsen,
können wir sie abkühlen.
Indem wir langsame Moleküle
mit schnellen in Kontakt bringen,
Etwas Kaltes mit etwas Warmen
in Kontakt bringen,
werden die schnellen Moleküle
abgebremst und so kühlt das Warme ab.
Je besser die Umgebung
die Wärme leitet,
desto schneller ist die Abkühlung.
Schauen wir mal,
wie kalt das jetzt ist.
Die Flasche hat im Gefrierfach
natürlich nur,
oder hauptsächlich,
Kontakt mit der Luft.
Luft ist ein sehr schlechter
Wärmeleiter.
Luft hat eine
sehr geringe Dichte, d.h.,
es gibt einfach wenige Moleküle, auf
die die Wärme übertragen werden kann.
Und wir haben hier immerhin 21,9°.
Normale Raumtemperatur.
Hat also nicht allzu viel gebracht.
Diese Flasche war 10 Minuten in Eis.
Hier hat sie natürlich ein bisschen
mehr Kontakt mit dem Eis selbst.
Aber der ist natürlich immer noch
sehr viel Luft dazwischen.
Wir haben jetzt auch nur 21,6°
Auch nicht besonders effektiv.
Wenn ich jetzt aber eine Mischung
aus Wasser und Eis nehme,
kann ich eine
bessere Kühlung erzielen.
Das mag auf den ersten Blick
etwas unintuitiv wirken,
weil man denkt,
Eis ist ja kälter als Wasser,
aber Wasser hat eine bessere
Wärmeleitung als Luft.
Außerdem hat so ein Wasser-Eisgemisch
auch ziemlich schnell
eine Temperatur von etwa 0°.
So haben wir jetzt nach 10 Minuten
schöne 9,1°.
Also fast Kühlschranktemperatur.
Noch besser wird es allerdings,
wenn wir etwas Salz oder Zucker,
oder irgendetwas,
das sich in Wasser löst, hinzugeben.
Hier tritt der Effekt der
"Gefrierpunktserniedrigung" auf.
Dasselbe nutzt man auch im Winter,
wenn man vereiste Straßen
mit Salz streut.
Sobald wir etwas im Wasser lösen,
erniedrigt das
den Gefrierpunkt des Wassers.
D.h., es gefriert nicht bei 0°,
sondern bei Minusgraden.
Bei einem Wasser-Eis-Salzgemisch
wird also der Gefrierpunkt
des Wassers erniedrigt,
das Eis fängt an zu schmelzen
und dieses Schmelzen
benötigt Energie.
Diese Energie wird in Form von Wärme
dem Gemisch entzogen.
Das Ganze wird
deutlich kälter als 0°.
Aua, das tut echt weh, wenn man
die Finger da länger reinhält.
Nach 10 Minuten haben wir
hier wunderbare 4,8°.
Das Beste ist, mit
dieser Wasser-Eis-Salzmischung
könnt ihr eure Getränke sogar
deutlich schneller runterkühlen
als in 10 Minuten.
Ich würde vorschlagen, wir machen
einen kleinen Community-Contest.
Ihr probiert das Zuhause aus
und schreibt in die Kommentare,
wie schnell ihr es hinbekommen habt,
euer Getränk von Raumtemperatur
auf Kühlschranktemperatur
runterzukühlen. Prost.
Schönschlau.
Und wenn ihr schon mal
am Kommentieren seid,
könnt ihr wie immer eure Fragen
mit in die Kommentare schreiben
und vielleicht kann ich sie dann
in einem Video beantworten.
Wir sehen uns nächsten
Donnerstag, bis dahin. Bleibt sicher.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2017)